have you ever wanted to build a website
but don't know where to start well
you're in luck because this video is
sponsored by Squarespace they're going
to help you with that more about them in
a bit in December 2003 New Jersey police
arrested Charles Cullen alerts at the
Somerset Medical Center and charged him
with one count of first-degree murder
and one count of attempted murder they
were convinced that Cullen had poisoned
two patients at the hospital he worked
at but none of them were prepared for
what the nurse had to reveal it wasn't
just two not even close it was dozens
possibly even hundreds Cullen had been
doing this for over a decade and a half
and nobody suspected a thing when
pressed for a motive the nurse trotted
out the same pathetic excuse always
given by these types of killers known as
angels of death he did it to end their
suffering Cullen knew that those
patients didn't have long to live and he
didn't want them to spend their final
moments on Earth in agony there was just
one problem with that flimsy explanation
many of his victims were not terminal
they could have gotten better left the
hospital and lived long and happy lives
if they weren't unfortunate enough to
run into Charles Cullen ultimately
Cullen's so-called compassion was
revealed for what it truly was a
murderous compulsion the outlet that the
nurse used whenever things went wrong in
his own life it had nothing to do with
the patience and it had all to do with
the fact that he enjoyed it scores of
people paid the price to turn Charles
Cullen into one of the most infamous
angels of death in American history
Charles Edmond Cullen was born on
February 22nd 1960 and West Orange New
Jersey the youngest of eight children of
Edmund and Florence Cullen by Cullen's
own admission his childhood was
miserable from birth he knew he was a
mistake an unwanted and unplanned
addition to a large family that were
already struggling to make ends meet he
was much much younger than his siblings
and some of them had already moved out
of the family home by the time he was
born his father who worked as a bus
driver died when Cullen was just seven
months old and his mother perished in a
car accident when Colin was a teenager
growing up he could hardly rely on his
siblings for companionship they were all
grown-ups who were struggling with their
own demons be they drug addictions
unwanted pregnancies or Shady boyfriend
who often bullied young Charles Cullen's
mother who was the only person in his
life who showed him any affection and
once she was gone he felt completely
alone he attempted suicide for the first
time something he did multiple times
during his lifetime with many attempts
resulting in stays in psychiatric
hospitals with nothing keeping him in
New Jersey anymore Cullen dropped out of
high school and joined the Navy in 1978.
he passed both the physical and the
psychological exams and served aboard a
nuclear submarine for a while however if
he hoped to find some kind of
camaraderie with his fellow servicemen
he was sadly mistaken these men always
stuck with each other for months at a
time in a tight enclosed space and with
Cullen being the weirdo of the group it
made him an easy target for hazing and
pranks he tried committing suicide again
and that got him sent to the Navy psych
ward Cullen began exhibiting strange
behavior during his time in the Navy the
most bizarre example occurred when his
Superior officer aboard the USS Woodrow
Wilson caught him sitting at the control
panel used for firing the submarine's
nuclear missiles dressed in surgical
gear instead of his Navy uniform
although Cullum wouldn't have been able
to fire the missiles he offered no
explanation for his behavior and he got
another psych evaluation eventually
Charles Cullen received a medical
discharge in 1984 for undisclosed
reasons with his Navy career behind him
Cullen returned to his home state he
could join the medical field and help
people when in reality he was getting
ready to embark on a campaign of death
and suffering the likes of which America
had never seen so Squarespace is the
all-in-one platform for building your
brand and growing a business online look
with Squarespace you can create a
beautiful website that stands out you
can engage with your audience you can
even sell products and services online
look I'm personally a huge fan of
Squarespace it's made everything super
easy I made my own website with
Squarespace it took less than an
afternoon it's that simple look if you
need a website for anything Squarespace
is the way to do it they've got loads of
cool stuff one thing that they have now
is member areas so you can create like a
gated part of your website which you can
sell access to and maybe I don't know
but some classes some courses some
exclusive content in there for your
members and you'll have an extra Revenue
stream for your business brilliant plus
with squarespaces email campaigns you
can collect email subscribers and
convert them to customers easy the
built-in analytics also measure the
impact of every email sent which is a
game changer for any business until I
mention that you can collect donations
if you're doing things for a course
through PayPal Apple pay stripe venmo
easy brilliant Squarespace so when
you're ready to get started go to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com biographics and you'll
save 10 of your first purchase of a
website or a domain and now back to
today's video
[Music]
the same year but Cullen had been
discharged from the Navy he enrolled at
Mountainside Hospital's nursing school
in Montclair New Jersey maybe for the
first time in his life things seemed
like they might turn out okay for
Charles Cullen the classes suited him
and so did the medical uniform that he
loved wearing being the only male
student there Cullen found a more
relaxing and familial atmosphere that
was devoid of the bullying and abuse
that had grown accustomed to his
classmates thought Cullen was bright and
hard-working and even elected in class
president a purely symbolic position
that nevertheless showed that Cullen
might have finally found a role in
society that fitted him perfectly to pay
for his schooling Cullen worked a
variety of part-time minimum wage jobs
and while mopping the floors at Roy
Rogers barbecue restaurant he even met a
girl a college grad named Adrian balm so
the untrained eye Charles Cullen seemed
like a good catch he was shy but
intelligent and handsome he was
dedicated to his career and worked
multiple jobs in order to graduate their
relationship progressed quickly six
months after their first date the couple
got engaged in 1987 Cullen graduated
from nursing school and he married
Adrian a week later they went on their
honeymoon to Niagara Falls and Upon
returning Cullen already had a job lined
up at the burn unit of the Saint
Barnabas Medical Center in Livingston
New Jersey soon after the marriage
Adrian gave birth to the first of two
daughters it seemed like everything
always coming up Aces for Carlin as he
settled into a life that many other
people would have envied but it wasn't
enough him despite his later
protestations that he only did what he
did to help people the darkness was
already inside him it had been growing
for a long time and it was now ready to
come out it's difficult to say with any
certainty who was Charles Cullen's first
victim or what exactly triggered his
murderous rage the earliest poisoning he
admitted to a 78 year old John yango
senior a former municipal judge who died
in the hospital on the 11th of June 1988
after being admitted with an allergic
reaction to a blood thinning drug this
was less than a year after going to
Saint Barnabas so clearly The Imposter
kill had been in Cullen all along Jenga
was supposed to avoid sunlight after
taking the medication something he was
on aware of the allergic reaction looked
very much like a bad sunburn and when
yengo died a couple of weeks later his
death was chalked up as an accident just
like that Cullen discovered how easy it
was to get away with murder and he had
no intention of stopping we're not sure
how many people Cullen killed at Saint
Barnabas at one point he claimed two
victims while on occasion he said four
or five he was never exact with his
figures which is why many people suspect
that he had a lot more victims than he
admitted to at least a dozen suspicious
deaths occurred at the hospital while
Cullen was a nurse there and truth be
told he can't be ruled out for any of
them something strange happened at the
hospital on February 11 1991. multiple
patients crashed with hypoglycemia for
no apparent reason that meant that their
blood sugar levels were dangerously low
and this was happening in several Wars
all over Saint Barnabas an inspection of
an IV bag showed that it contained high
levels of insulin even though the only
substances inside were supposed to be
Heparin and saline one case could have
been a mistake but multiple suggested
that someone had done it on purpose
hospital security launched an
investigation into matter and they
arrived at Charles Cullen pretty quickly
he was one of only three nurses who were
there for every code he dismissed their
attempts for interview though and once
he was finally accused of spiking the IV
bags Cullen Cooley and carelessly told
them that they couldn't prove anything
and ultimately it was right Hospital
knew he did it they even suspected that
he may have done it in the past but they
didn't find anything solid to point to
Cullen so with few Alternatives they
just simply stopped calling him for
shift work in early 1992 Charles Cullen
began his search for his next workplace
slash hunting ground the almost four
years he spent in Saint Barnabas became
the longest position of his career as he
would go on to change jobs another nine
times before being caught things weren't
going any better at home but Cullen
didn't really care actually the fact
that he didn't care was the problem
although his wife was initially filled
with respect and adulation for her
husband it didn't take long for her to
realize that something was off with him
it seems that Cullen was only capable of
showing any kind of emotional or
affection towards one thing in his life
first his wife was the focus
then her Yorkshire Terrier lady then a
new puppy then the baby and finally
their second baby but as soon as
something new came along everything and
everyone who came before it held no
interest for Cullen it was almost as if
they stopped existing for him an
emotional neglect aside Adrian Cullen
suspected husband a far more disturbing
things she was fairly certain that he
spiked people's drinks for fun that he
killed the neighbor's dog Queenie and
even that he drugged his own infant
daughters to stop them from crying
eventually she realized that she needed
to get away from Cullen for her sake and
the sake of her two children she
divorced him in 1993 and took a
restraining order out against him she
thought she understood the kind of man
that Charles Cullum really was but even
she could unfathom the true extent of
his murderous depravity
foreign
was falling apart Cullen had found work
at Warren Hospital in Phillipsburg New
Jersey where he killed at least three
elderly female patients with digoxin he
also tried to commit suicide again and
spent some time in the hospital's
psychiatric ward where he befriended
another nurse named Michelle Tomlinson
they went out on a date together but
Michelle proved more Adept at piercing
through the facade of normalcy that
Cullen had erected and seeing the true
wretch that hid within him she wanted
nothing more to do with Charles Cullen
but this was hard to do since they
worked at the same place and he wasn't
the type to take no for an answer he
would bring a gift schedule shifts
together and leave her dozens of
messages eventually he started stalking
her and at one point even broke into her
home he even admitted to the deed
casually not thinking he had done
anything wrong unsurprisingly this
resulted in an arrest which led to yet
another attempted suicide and to stay at
a psych hospital it seems that everyone
in Cullen's life his wife Michelle the
psychiatrists and counselors who treated
him they could all see to varying
degrees that Charles Cullen was a
disturbed man but none of them at the
slightest inclinations of what he truly
was capable of in 1994 Cullen found
another job at Hunterdon Hospital in
Flemington New Jersey he later claimed
that he wanted to stop being a nurse but
was forced to do it in order to pay
child support most likely this was yet
another way for him to excuse his
murderous impulses and pass the blame on
to someone else oddly enough hunterton
thought they stumbled upon a real winner
when Cullen came to work for them for
almost two years he was something of a
star pupil among the hospital's nursing
staff and his October 1995 performance
report said that Cullen was a patient
advocate organized very giving him his
time so much to offer very bright witty
and intelligence we don't know what
brought on this new and improved Charles
Cullen it might have just been the
affections of another nurse named Kathy
who dated him for a while she was
already trapped in an unhappy marriage
and hoped that the new hotshot male
nurse would be a step away from that
suffice it to say that that wasn't the
case no matter how bad her husband was
unless he wants moonlighted as the
Zodiac he was probably nowhere near as
bad as Charles Cullen their relationship
fizzled out in late 1995 and then we saw
Cullen revert to type he became
exceedingly sloppy at work making all
sorts of medication errors and remaining
completely nonchalant whenever he was
reprimanded for it he also resumed
killing again clearly he felt like he
had some ground to make up for those two
years that he wasted trying to be a
model employee Cullen murdered at least
five people in the first half of 1996
until he finally got the sack from
hunterton but still nobody thought he
was a killer just a bad worker therefore
Cullen had no problem making the short
drive from Flemington to Morris Town and
finding a new job there at the
Morristown Memorial Hospital this time
though Caitlin came in with a chip on
his shoulder and was a problem employee
from the outset he was let go after less
than a year for his poor performance and
according to his own estimates he didn't
kill too many people just one or two and
it's unclear if he did this on purpose
or just due to carelessness either way
by late summer 1996 Cullen always out of
a job but he didn't feel like getting a
new one just yet he did what he always
did whenever he wanted attention he
swallowed a bunch of bills and dolled
9-1-1 he knew that he would be taken to
the hospital and hopefully sent for
another stay at Greystone the
psychiatric hospital that he had grown
accustomed to that was Cullen's version
of a vacation whenever he was unsure of
how to proceed next he tried suicide and
got himself committed he stayed there
until December 1997 and he came out with
a new plan for 1998. leave New Jersey
when Cullen left Greystone he decided
that it was time for a change of scenery
so he traveled West to Pennsylvania once
again he found a new job without much of
a hassle by using a staffing agency this
time the Liberty nursing and rehab
center in Allentown Cullen even listed
his former hospitals as references he
always did this and yet he still passed
the background checks it seems that all
his former employees were more worried
about lawsuits than protecting their
patients and considered that their best
course of action was to say nothing
instead of making accusations that they
could improve therefore the worst
endorsement that Cullen got were simple
confirmations that he indeed used to
work for them with no added details and
then of course the inevitable happened
Cullen killed again this time it was an
elderly man named Francis Henry who had
a broken vertebra who was certainly not
a life-threatening condition but
Cullen's personal life was in the gutter
hysteric Greystone meant he didn't work
for a year he was tens of thousands of
dollars in debt and behind on alimony
payments he needed an outlet for his
rage and unfortunately Mr Henry was in
the wrong place at the wrong time Cullen
stint at Liberty nursing was short-lived
but once again he was fired for his
subpar performance not for his homicidal
Tendencies but that was all right
because the nursing agency immediately
found him another post just a few miles
down the road in eastern Pennsylvania
and that's where he killed another
elderly man named ottomashram and before
the internal investigation into his
death was even finished Cullen already
had another position at Lehi Valley
Hospital back in Allentown he spent
about a year there and became an outcast
among the nursing staff it was getting
more and more difficult for him to
maintain a normal front not but he ever
tried too hard and his co-workers wanted
nothing to do with him according to his
own admissions which he made with the
same vagueness that others have when
trying to recall odd football scores
Cullen thought he probably killed about
four or five people at Lehi although
only two were identified from records in
April 2000 Charles Cullen began work at
his new place of employment in Luke's
Hospital in Fountain Hill Pennsylvania
this was a prestigious positions and
Luke's was rated as one of the best
hospitals in the country it was
expanding and it needed extra Manpower
it seems like Cullen's years of terrible
work and killing patients were finally
being rewarded with the perfect job the
nurse spent almost three years at Saint
Luke's a time during which he killed at
least five people he never really liked
it there his behavior was becoming
stranger and more erratic obviously the
worst was only poison patients but other
times he would act more like a petulant
child throwing a fit Carlin would dump
medications down the toilet or in the
bin just to cost Hospital money he would
take a wheelchairs a ride before his
shift and leave them in random rooms
just so the other nurses wasted their
time looking for them eventually the
star found some unused drugs thrown in a
disposal bin and traced them to Cullen
but just as before investigations were
long and costly and opened the window
for lawsuit so Cullum was given the
opportunity to resign in exchange for
neutral references making it easy for
him to find another position at a
different hospital and if he's sitting
there wondering how it was possible for
so many hospitals to downplay Cullen's
Behavior allowing him to get rehired
time and time again and Gilmore patience
well it's about to get a whole lot worse
because even though by this point
Charles Cullen had already poisoned
dozens of people he was just now about
to embark on his deadliest murder spree
at the very least it seems that the
higher upsets and Luke's made some
unofficial inquiries into Cullen they
called up other hospitals in the area
warning them not to have any dealings
with the Troublesome nurse suddenly
Cullen was finding it hard to keep a
steady job some places simply stopped
scheduling shifts for him while others
called him and straight up told him not
to show up anymore but it was a big
country out there and the people at
Saint Luke's didn't talk with anyone
outside their immediate region or the
police or the state nursing board or
anyone else who could have taken some
more effective measures therefore when
work dried up the Cullen in Pennsylvania
he just moved back to New Jersey in
September 2002 where he finally found a
new position at the Somerset Medical
Center in Somerville during his time
there Cullen befriended another nurse
named Amy Logan he became a close
Confidant of hers and it seemed like
this new relationship was enough to
Stave off his murderous impulses for a
while but lothren suffered from
cardiomyopathy and eventually required a
pacemaker which put her on the shelf for
a while losing her even temporarily send
Cullen off the deep end and he responded
with the least Soul viciousness unlike
he had ever exhibited before the madness
started around February 2003 and lasted
until October nine months of unchecked
Fury during which Charles Cullen
murdered at least 13 people and possibly
many many more it was in July that the
administration suspected something might
be wrong in their Hospital following the
death of a 68 year old priest Reverend
Florian Gaul his autopsy revealed
abnormally high levels of dioxin in his
system they sent his findings to the New
Jersey Poison Control Center who
launched an investigation soon enough
they pointed the finger at Charles
Cullen who had never been particularly
diligent when it came to covering up his
tracks the Poison Control Center spotted
a pattern with Cullen and warned summer
said that they might have a Serial
poisoner on their hands and in the
hospital do anything about this well yes
but with the swiftness of a three-legged
tortoise once again fear of lawsuits and
bad publicity led to the wheel of
Justice turning exceedingly slowly it
wasn't until October that he was fired
and the somerset prosecutor's office was
alerted to his activities between July
and October Cullen had killed at least
five more people to their credit the
prosecutor and the detectives who
investigated Cullen operated with a
greater sense of urgency they got the
case in October 2003 and on December
12th Charles Cullen was in custody the
detectives probably could have arrested
him even sooner but they were
stonewalled every time they tried to
interview people from the hospitals
where Cullen had previously worked the
Witnesses were always accompanied by
corporate lawyers Risk Managers and
administrators who weren't there to get
to the truth or to help catch Cullen but
to ensure that nothing they said created
any liability for them after all nobody
wanted to admit that they were the ones
who gave a serial killer free reign to
operate in their hospital but then came
Amy lafren she wanted to find out the
truth even if it cost her a job she was
fiercely defensive of Cullen who was
still a close friend but the more she
listened to the cops the more things
started to make sense slowly but surely
Amy realized the ship befriended a
monster ultimately she proved
instrumental in Catching Cullen by
agreeing to wear a wire and meet him at
a diner where he implicated himself not
only in the poisonings in Somerset but
going so far back as some Barnabas oh
when the cops arrested Cullen they only
charged him with the murder of the
Reverend and another attempted murder
but this time the nurse had a bombshell
for them colored admitted to killing 30
to 40 people over the previous 16 years
unsurprisingly Cullen's sentencing
became merely a formality since he pled
guilty in exchange for dropping the
death penalty the angel of death that he
became known throughout the country was
given over a dozen life sentences which
he's currently serving at the New York
State Prison in Trenton he's eligible
for parole in 2388.